these days here's my question when you
you know the face of wokeness in the
face of you know all this super
progressiveness at the end of the day
our college campus liberals 20 something
year olds gen Z is this sort of just
every generation the young people are
going to have their causes they identify
with and it is what it is and they're
the future sorry 68 year old 72 year
olds 80 year olds it's not your time has
come and gone and move on it's now gen Z
time the woke time how much of that is
just on them and this is their
philosophy and they're the future and
it's like it is what it is Buddy how
much of that is on them
I wish unfortunately it's on us and you
know this actually is a perfect way to
get back to your question about uh
education
problem or at least I would argue one of
the most major problems is that we have
broken the mechanism by which young
people come to understand how the world
functions
now that has happened in a number of
different ways but it has accelerated
very rapidly in the last decade or two
um because of the iPhone I'm assuming in
the internet
it could have been a lot of things it
happened to be those two and a few more
um you know porn lots of stuff but the
the problem if you think back into what
human beings fundamentally are
human beings are a creature in which you
have the hardware package the body and
you have a software package that is
loaded in after the child is born
primarily
that software package is capable of
turning you into anything you can be an
Inuit hunting large sea mammals by kayak
right or you can be a Maasai herdsman or
you can be a collector of swallow nests
in a cave in China right a human being
can be a lot of different things based
on what software package it gets right
it can be an Aztec
um
but what it cannot do is live in a world
where by the time an individual becomes
an adult the software program that it
picked up in childhood is already
obsolete there is no mechanism to deal
with that world where it is changing so
rapidly that the world you're born into
is gone before you become an adult and
that's the world that we're living in in
our case it happens to surround
Technologies like iPhones like the
internet like pornography these things
are radically altering the realities
and this then brings us back to the
question of what would we what should we
do to fix education and the
the answer at least a big part of it
is actually staring Us in the face
what
is so distorting about the technologies
that come to us through screens is that
they are not obligated to adhere to
rules
right on the internet if you say that
you're a woman then I guess you are
right because who's going to say
differently right in reality if you're a
man and you say that you're a woman
there's something to talk about right
that doesn't appear that doesn't match
the person I see standing in front of me
so the way to
take a generation and
educate it so that it does not grow up
to be
um a world full of suckers is to force
education to include
things that are obligated to rules
especially physical rules
so when Heather and I were teaching
among the things that we did was we
would assign students to
teach themselves any skill right we had
an assignment we we called learn a skill
and the idea was it didn't matter what
skill it was but it had one requirement
the skill had to be one where you didn't
need some person to tell you whether you
had succeeded or failed it had to be
obvious if you were gonna build tables
they had to stand up they had to be
level right you don't need someone to
tell you you did or you didn't build a
table right you didn't or you didn't fix
an engine you did or you didn't play a
song that sounded musical right those
are all physical realities and the
reason that that is so important
is that in a world where everything that
you learn is learned socially right you
can be persuaded of things that are
absolutely false right if the professor
at the front of the room is a fool
but they are in charge of your grade and
they say lots of foolish things and you
dutifully write them down in your
notebook and then you spit them back out
on the test you are being anti-educated
right that's never going to happen in
the context of an engine or a garden or
anything where it's physics that
dictates whether or not you succeeded or
it's biology that dictates whether or
not you've succeeded so my point would
be somebody who gets really good at
operating in the physical world is not
going to be a fool right they may you
know lack some skills they may not be
able to do calculus they may not be
articulate but they won't be a fool and
so we have to include these mechanisms
that are not socially conveyed in our
education at a high level and frankly
most people can go through school and
never encounter these things they're no
longer a part of the regular curriculum
would you do us a favor and go maybe
slightly deeper and take a sort of an
abstract idea and be very specific like
what are you doing with with your 16 and
18 year old kids to educate them so they
don't become fools and victims of modern
society uh you know we do all kinds of
things we troubleshoot our vehicles when
they fail we
build additions onto our house we fix
the plumbing when it's not working and
you know these things they're not only
incredibly useful but they're also
rewarding right there's nothing quite
like taking something that isn't working
for reasons that are mysterious going
through the process which by the way
ends up being a scientific process where
you determine what it is that must be
going wrong with it and then you
discover hey I must have had that right
because there it is working now right
that's a very rewarding process it's
very interesting because you I would say
you know obviously you get paid to use
your brain in your mouth but you're
making your kids use their hands to
accomplish things that must be very
intentional well it is and it isn't you
know I sort of grew up as a tinkerer I
was always when people would come to do
work on the house I grew up in I would
follow them around like a puppy dog
watching everything they did
understanding how the house worked and
and all of those things and so you know
it's it's not like I have to go out of
my way to teach this lesson it's it's
intuitive but it also it works like
gangbusters some may say you're just
getting free labor out of your kids I
don't know that is definitely also the
case so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
foreign
[Music]